[Music]
coached hi daddy Eric Ebron making this
observation while watching the combine
these young linebackers running for
point four I got to put the honey buns
oh and there is some fast fast forty
times yesterday from the linebackers in
the defensive end fastest forty times
ever for the group
how about Montes sweat 260 plus pounds
four for one linebacker Devin white for
four Oh Chris how important is that one
to ten I mean it's up there I'm gonna
say it's somewhere between you know I'm
gonna go like an eight or a nine I mean
it's not gonna be again everything but
when you see times like that from guys
where on film they look explosive it's
just going to go oh okay he is every bit
as explosive as I thought he was looking
at the film certainly and it just shows
that what it also shows teams when man
when these guys train the proper way and
do things Wow look at the specimens they
can develop into but I thought
yesterday's workouts on Sunday deadlines
and linebackers it might have been the
most impressive Sunday I can remember as
far as the defensive side of the ball
the front seven guys so many freakish
athletes I just again thinks it speaks
to how popular football is in our
country right now and how kids are going
all-in on one sport at the age of 13 and
14 and they're you know going to camps
and and training for football all year
round and that's what we're seeing now
some freaky athletes really on both
sides of the ball but I mean sweat Devon
white Devon Bushra Sean Gary those two
from Michigan they were off the charts I
mean it really was a specimen show
yesterday as far as the defense is
concerned and I wonder why this year
it's clustered in that spot is it just a
statistical anomaly or is there is there
something to be said for you know the
the bigger guys learning the techniques
they're not just big heavy guys they're
getting stronger they're getting faster
they're getting the most out of their
frame they're putting the most bulk on
it and they're finding the best way to
move from point A to point B yeah I
think so it's become a little bit more
of a science test you know as far as
a specimen for football we're yeah guys
like Montes sweat or a Devon white from
LSU when their season ended I mean
they've been living to a tee the last
six weeks as far as just healthy eating
correct training correct rest correct
you know ways to you know recharge the
body so you can go at it again hard the
next day all of those things the science
the sports science around football and
training is only improved and of course
yes you're getting at high school in
college and then even going to another
level once you get into these combine
process but I just think it's yeah
there's this is one of those years where
the defensive line the list is
never-ending as far as specimens and and
quality football players and I think
we're kind of onto something here from
the standpoint that the NFL wants
everything to be the same year in and
year out so it's basically an open-book
test for all of the prospects and here
we are 40 50 years into this thing where
and and at least 15 where it's a huge
huge deal you know exactly what is
expected of you and and and the
preparation process has been perfected
because it never changes Chris so every
year the people who train these guys get
a little bit better at getting them
ready because they know every year what
they're gonna face right physically they
know the drill they can get them ready
for it yes every year is another base of
experiences that they can use with those
clients to help get the next wave of
clients even more prepared so the the
times get faster because the guys get
better at running the forty they're not
better football players but they're
better at running the 40 right they're
better at doing the drills because the
drills never change yes the drills never
change you find ways from like you're
saying year to year to go ooh maybe if
we change this technique we can be we
can shave off a tenth or a second or a
hundredth of a second you know and then
of course the advanced training
techniques it's ongoing you know
especially in the the sport of the NFL
or football in general just how to
become bigger faster stronger how to
become more efficient in those areas and
I think that's what we're seeing and
that
why we're seeing I mean Montes sweat
yesterday that was a freak show and I
say that respectfully as you know but
that was just I mean that was jus Devi
on clowny miles Garrett first pick of
the draft type of stuff where this guy
was running down and running as fast as
you know why we make a big deal about
Dewayne Haskins running a 5.0 four at
the quarterback position because guys
like that are chasing them or guys like
Dexter Lorenz from Clemson or 348 pounds
they ran a five point zero eight so
that's why we make a big deal when a
quarterback runs a slow time or anything
like that but if you're watching on TV I
mean holy cow does this Montez sweat
kids special I mean what a specimen and
he killed it at the Senior Bowl too and
he's really made himself a lot of money
the last few weeks
Nick Bose is gonna make himself a lot of
money the brother of Joey Bosa who is
going to be making even more money when
he gets his second contract Nick BOCES
numbers in many respects better than his
brothers he is an inch and a half
shorter but faster in the 45 more reps
in the 225 pound benchpress not as much
of a broad jump a little bit slower on
the three cone a little faster on the
20-yard shuttle how important are Nick
BOCES numbers on a scale of one to ten
yeah there again there they're up there
but first of all the body he type he has
I mean gosh is he built to play defense
and holy cow when you talk about legs
and butt I mean those are some of the
first things I look at when I evaluate
these defensive line linebacker
positions it's a it's a position of
power and explosion and he's built to
come around the corner and dip his
shoulder and have a 300-pound tackle
hanging on his back where he can still
run around it and do it so I think he
proved yesterday that he is certainly a
top five pick and I think that was
already known even before this but the
numbers just justify all of it and it's
really again not about the 40 time when
you look at it like in Nick boza as much
as we hey we'd love him to run a montes
sweat type of time the 10-yard split for
these defensive ends it's really the
biggest number a lot of teams will look
at and boast of had a 10-yard split that
is you know up there with the top-tier
pass rushers in all of football and I
think that at the end of the day was
work ethic in this film are all gonna be
looked at and just go yeah this guy's a
specimen and he's certainly one of the
better players in the draft the specimen
of all specimens DK Metcalf the
Mississippi receiver they got it's scary
it looks photoshopped every photo of him
does not look real the guy is jacked his
muscles have muscles he's 6 3 2 28 he
ran the 40 and 4.3 3 seconds he did the
225 benchpress 27 times but he had his
first season at Mississippi cut way
short due to a foot injury his most
recent season cut short due to a neck
injury there are durability questions
his production wasn't tremendous what
are you getting if you get DK Metcalfe
as a guy who can run routes and catch
passes yeah and you know what I haven't
got to do my deep dive in this yet so I
will certainly be able to tell you more
and more as we get to the draft process
as far as just evaluating them but from
what I know from what I've seen a little
bit on film what I saw on TV I mean the
kid is it's Julio Jones ish Mike what
this kid can bring to the table
yeah health is certainly gonna be the
big issue when all said and done and can
he stay on the field and teams are gonna
have to feel comfortable about his
injury history but regardless 6 3 2 28 4
3 3 I mean that's just insane and that
is like what I let's say is like oh this
is this is the new this is the new
10-year updated version of Julio Jones
who came out in 2000 you know what was
that the 10 draft 2011 11 but it just
again I think shows you the specimens
are only to get better as we go along
right just how you kind of started off
talking about this to start the segment
you know you're just the the training
the attention the detail as far as your
body route running everything like that
it just continues to get better and
better and DK Metcalf was a star among
stars on the Saturday workout and is
going to be probably a top 10 top 12
pick especially now that he hammered at
home with these numbers and I guess that
would be my concern how much of this
stuff that we're seeing the guy carving
off 0.02 from his 40 time how much of it
is an illusion
and how much of it means I'm really
getting a better football player because
some of these advanced training
techniques will give you a better
football player that's right but what
you're getting this weekend is a better
underwear Olympian yeah necessarily a
better football player and that's where
I think that that's where the challenge
is with we've talked about the workout
words all the time Vernon Golson Mike
mamooli you don't want to be that guy
but there's always the potential for
that guy to be floating around yeah
there is that guy and that that's where
again the biggest thing will be the film
when you watch it you know you're gonna
watch the film and all the other numbers
that go along with it you know when
you're running four three three and then
all your other explosion numbers are off
the charts as to is whether it's the
broad jump or the 40 inch vertical which
is like MBA slam dunk contest type of
numbers like that's when all the coaches
are gonna go wait okay the film he's
fast he's big explosive holy cow all his
numbers that talk about explosion are
off the charts to where then you could
see other combine guys like you're
talking about who have mastered a
certain part of the test right where wow
they ran a good 40 time but their
vertical leap was only like 29 inches
and their broad jumps not that very good
that's when I look at things and go oh
they've mastered the science of the 40
but I'm not so sure they're exactly
gifted explosive wise when I look at
their other numbers and that's where
you're like you're saying you're gonna
have to balance that out and go watch
the film ago was this guy just a really
good science experiment and had the 40
down or is the the explosion really
legit and true and that's the a that's
why GM's and head coaches are paid big
money
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports